wir haben da tote tiere gesehen wir
haben da tiere mitgenommen die nicht mal
an die mittel trinken kam weil sie
gebrochene beine hatten
der skandal an der sache ist ja
eigentlich auch dass solche aufnahmen
nur über tierschützerinnen überhaupt in
die medien kommen letztendlich kannst du
in jedem stall horror aufnahmen machen
kannst du auch bei uns im steuer machen
unsere buchten beide sehr doch dann
leider auch das wasser aussehen
ich habe das gefühl wir haben vergessen
dass töten bedeutung
was denkt ihr ist die wurst die
zigarette der zukunft im schnitt essen
wir in deutschland immerhin noch 60 kilo
fleisch pro jahr der trend geht aber
trotzdem immer mehr in richtung
vegetarisch und das ja auch irgendwie
kein wunder oder klimakiller schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen massentierhaltung der
ruf des fleisches es eigentlich kaum
noch zu retten sind veganer innen und
vegetarierinnen schlicht die besseren
menschen und fleischesser erinnern
einfach willensschwach genau darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen wir bei 310
fragen ich möchte beide lager westen
teils zum kompromiss führen aber die
erste frage geht erst mal an euch was
meint ihr darf man noch fleisch essen
schreibt mir die kommentare dann eröffne
ich mit der ersten runde das erstmal
eine schnelle runde ohne worte zweite
frage von 13 fragen an euch wer von euch
ist fleisch wenn ihr sagt ja ich esse
fleisch dann geht ihr bitte aufs gelbe
fällt wenn er sagt nein ich esse kein
fleisch dann geht die bitte aus
grünefeld
ich esse gerne fleisch ab und zu
jedenfalls weil ich denke dass es zu
einer gesunden ernährung mit dazugehört
ich esse kein fleisch weil ich es
ethisch nicht vertretbar finde tote
tiere zu essen ist das in deutschland
möglich guten gewissens fleisch zu essen
was sagt ihr ja oder nein
ob etwas moralisch vertretbar ist wer
entscheidet das denn also ich habe
meinen weg gefunden ich esse das fleisch
was ich selbst erlebe und habe damit ein
reines gewissen und freue mich über das
was ich bei mir auf dem teller habt
fleisch essen muss heutzutage eigentlich
niemand mehr wir leben in so einer
privilegierten gesellschaft und
situationen es geht darum dass wir im
hier und jetzt sofort damit aufhören
können vierte frage von 13 fragen ist es
moralisch vertretbar tiere für den
persönlichen genuss zu töten
also ich denke der mensch hat sich schon
immer irgendwo auch von fleisch in der
natürlich nicht nur und ich denke da
wird sich auch nicht großartig was dann
ändern wir sind so gesehen allesfresser
und das ist auch völlig in ordnung so
die mochte den geschmack von tierischen
produkten früher sehr sehr gerne und
dachte ein leben ohne tierische produkte
wer gar nicht lebenswert aber in
gewissen punkten musste mir die frage
stellen ist denn dieser kurze moment des
genusses wirklich eine rechtfertigung
für das leid dass meine frühere
lebensweise verursacht hat und die
antwort für mich war nein und das war
der moment als ich aufgehört habt
irische gute zuerst ok zweite runde es
gibt übrigens vier runden also es wird
noch spannend die nächste frage geht an
euch ob schlacht fabrik biohof beide
schlachtung am ende muss ein tier
sterben damit wir essen können und das
in einem der reichsten länder der welt
in dem wir uns auch ohne fleisch gesund
ernähren können was meint ihr sollten
wir schlachthöfe abschaffen wenn ja dann
könnt ihr jetzt einen schritt auf mich
zukommen wenn nicht dann bleibt er
einfach stehen ganz nicht abschaffen
muss weil ich glaube die zukunft inhalt
auch das gleich mit unserer ernährung
gehören aber in der größenordnung
johanna sagst du dazu
also ich finde sich auch ein schwieriges
thema ich bin auch sehr dafür dass man
das ganze regionaler gestalt und wieder
mehr kleine schlachthöfe schafft aber
sie nicht komplett abschafft
schlachthöfe könnte ich persönlich
verzichten ich finde aber die frage ist
zu allgemein formuliert weil sowas wie
wiesen schlachtungen finde ich zb also
befürworte ich zum beispiel in bezug auf
die tötung des tieres sehr aber ich bin
halt ganz überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen
sage ich mal mit einem schlachthof wo am
tag 22.000 schweine geschlachtet werden
ok dann bleibt erstmal stehen wir gucken
erst mal wie es bei euch aus sieht der
trend geht ja immer mehr in richtung
fleischlose ernährung also selbst große
fleisch hersteller innen setzen
mittlerweile auf veganer und auf
vegetarische alternativen und trotzdem
fordern veganer innen immer weiter dass
wir gar keins mehr essen
wieso reicht es nicht wenn man einfach
weniger fleisch essen benehmen ihr
zustimmt dann kommt gern einen schritt
auf mich zu und wenn ich dann bleibt
einfach stehen
also natürlich wäre es weniger schlecht
aber das mattes und unbedingt gut von
daher keine ahnung also letztlich selbst
genauso wie nico jeder kleine schritt
ist ein guter schritt in die richtige
richtung in richtung mehr bewusstsein
für das thema aber am ende des tages
rechtfertigen wir immer noch das töten
eines lebewesens und das wünschen wir
glaube ich nicht es gibt ja auch diesen
begriff flexitarier also leute die eher
selten fleisch essen die us problem ist
ja was das mit einem macht es auch dass
man schnell ein gutes gewissen sich
einredet und sagt ich mache das ja nur
ganz wenig oder ich kaufe nur bio oder
man hat ja immer so seine ausreden aber
wieder normalisieren das töten von
lebewesen die wie unsere hunde zu hause
wie katzen zu hause einfach den wunsch
haben zu leben und wie du ja schon am
anfang gesagt hast wir sind nicht drauf
angewiesen also wenn wir eine
gewaltfreie aktion haben warum sollte
man es keine gewaltvoll entscheiden ob
das würde ich auch nicht nur einmal in
der woche ein hund schlagen da sagt
jetzt gutes gewissen bedeutet das wer
fleisch isst sollte ein schlechtes
gewissen haben
also wir haben oft kein schlechtes
gewissen weil wir uns in einer
gesellschaft leben die das total
normalisiert hatten also ich hab auch 26
jahre meines lebens jeden tag massiv zu
vergessen ich habe es sehr gefeiert
und ich glaube wenn das bewusstsein erst
mal da ist das bewusstsein muss erstmal
geschaffen werden also diese verbindung
wieder herzustellen
von diesem produkt was im regal ist was
in plastik verpackt ist zudem was hinter
den kulissen passiert müssen wir erstmal
wieder herstellen deswegen nein ich
finde nicht dass von persien schlechtes
gewissen haben muss
aber man sollte sich also jeder der
fleisch konsumiert sollte einmal hinter
die kulissen schauen was da passiert und
wie das essen hergestellt wird
[Musik]
es gibt ja sehr häufig innerhalb dieser
diskussion
den vorwurf in sage mal eure richtung in
die richtung der veganer innen in die
richtung der vegetarier erinnern was ihr
missionieren würdet jetzt würde mich mal
an eurer seite interessieren fühlt ihr
euch jetzt so als würden da die guten
menschen stehen und ihr seid die
schlechten und die bevormunden euch was
sagst du johanna also ich sehe es gar
nicht so ich finde es völlig in ordnung
ich denke jeder sollte auch selber
wählen dürfen was er denn essen möchte
und was nicht was ich halt immer
schwierig finde ist wenn es irgendwo
eine religion wird quasi und jetzt jeder
unbedingt sich vegan ernähren muss man
das läuten aufzwingen will religion per
se kann seine zahlen weil er religion
ist ja der glaube an etwas überirdisches
was man nicht wirklich verifizieren kann
aber das leid von tsr greifbares und
missionieren eben hat diesen religiös
kommentierten begriff letztendlich
versuchen vegan lebende menschen nur
dass leib was sie sehen halt sichtbar zu
machen
ich meine auch nicht dass er es als
religion an seht aber manchen hat man
halt das gefühl dass ihr wollt dass
damit nur ausdrücken es geht uns ja gar
nicht darum irgend jemand was
aufzutreten können wir ja gar nicht wir
können niemand etwas zwingen was wir
aber tun es wird zwingen den tieren ihr
tod auf also wir zwingen sie die haben
gar keine wahl sie hat keine stimme sie
habe keine möglichkeit sich zu äußern
ich bin narkose arzt also selbst wenn
ich einem tier eine narkose verpassen
würde und das tier wäre würde nichts
mitbekommen ich würde meinem kopf und
zum beispiel auch keine narkose passen
ihm die kehle aufschlitzen und sagen ist
ja egal er nichts mitbekommen
es ist ja unmoralisch das zu tun wenn
man es nicht muss das ist ansichtssache
also die diskussion finde ich
tatsächlich sehr sehr schwierig weil es
endlich eine ähnliche diskussion ist wie
ist blau oder rot das schöner ich weiß
ethisch moralisch was anderes aber ich
denke da werden wir nicht auf einen
nenner kommen und selbst zu einigen ob
es okay ist ihre zu töten oder nicht
aber wird zu sagen schwein empfinden
schmerz natürlich haben schweine den
wunsch zu leben mit sicherheit warum
sein wir sie nehmen weil wir schon immer
uns auch von fleisch ernährt haben schon
immer tiere getötet haben wir schon für
immer gemacht oder was wir heute als
unethisch an sondern würdest du sagen
dass die menschheit den letzten 10.000
jahren nur dinge immer schon gemacht hat
die in ordnung waren und dass wir
niemals und ein punkt gesagt haben hey
was wir schon immer getan haben ist doch
unethisch und ländern ist natürlich
nicht aber letztendlich thematik wolf
der wolf ist er so gesehen auch
unethisch gefragter schaaf wir haben
auch nicht darf ich dich jetzt bittet
der meilenstein der mensch unterscheidet
sich von nicht-menschlichen tieren weil
er über eine moral und ethik verfügt und
sich seines verstandes bedienen kann und
das ist das wo wir sagen wir sind quasi
besser als tiere weil wir stellen uns ja
an die spitze der nahrungskette ich
finde es teilweise schwierig wenn mir
jemand sagt ich es zum beispiel gerne
alle zwei wochen ein stück fleisch aus
gute haltungsform und und finde es
schwierig wenn mir jemand sagt das was
du machst ist ganz ganz schlecht ich
glaube nicht dass wir etwas in der
gesellschaft bewegen wenn man im
erhobenen zeigefinger kommt ich glaube
das geht nur wenn man den leuten
alternativen aufzeigt und und das nicht
verteufelt was die sagen klar das thema
hey wir haben schon immer
tiere getötet und das ist nicht
unbedingt gut ist es auch ein anderes
thema aber das ist kultur das ist ein
stück weit kultur dass wir tiere essen
und das werden wir auch nicht
easy und ganz schnell wieder raus
kriegen da kam mir gleich weiter darüber
dass wir haben noch genug zeit dafür
treten gerne die nächste runde eröffnen
und stars auch zeit für eure
persönlichen erfahrung die siebte frage
geht an dich johanna deine schweine die
haben 30 prozent mehr platz als
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben also ein
quadratmeter pro schwein stadt 0,75
quadratmeter pro schwein
hier ist es also schon noch wichtig dass
es seinen tieren gut geht würdest du
denn sagen dass du sie artgerecht hältst
auf jeden fall also ich stehe voll
hinter dem was wir auf den betrieb tun
sonst würde ich so nicht machen würde
ich nicht dahinter stehen artgerecht
finde ich tatsächlich immer schwierig
ich bin der meinung auch die katze in
einer einraumwohnung wird nicht
artgerecht gehalten artgerecht wäre
tatsächlich wir machen den stall
komplett aufbauen auch keinen zaun
sondern lassen sie wie die wildschweine
draußen rum rennen funktioniert aber
nicht so ganz vor allem auch nicht bei
denen grob 3500 schweine wie am tag
brauchen in berlin also nicht brauchen
aber aktuell konsumiert werden in berlin
das funktioniert nicht jemand sprechen
brauchen wir irgendwo stelle und da
finde ich unseren schon wirklich sehr
sehr schön ist es nicht nur der platz
der mehr ist wir haben mehr licht im
stall wir haben beschäftigung ist
material strom minimal einstreu und ich
stehe voll dahinter
auf jeden fall was sagt ihr dazu bewegt
euch das ein schritt nach vorne
auf gar keinen fall also du hast es ja
gesagt die tür aufmachen und dann in
freiheit und die tiere werden ja auch
dafür gezüchtet damit man sie dann eben
über einen kurzen zeitraum einsperrt
eingesperrt hält messe und dann eben für
den verzehr schlachtet ich habe das
gefühl wir haben vergessen dass töten
bedeutet also ich habe manchmal so
einigen fragezeichen im kopf und drückt
also duells tja da wurde sich bewegt
warum jeweils das definitiv der fall ist
also ich würde mal behaupten dass 90
prozent
der deutschen einwohner überhaupt keine
vorstellung davon hat wie ein tier lebt
gehalten wird transportiert und
geschlachtet wird
und da bin ich mir also würde ich mir
sehr sicher ich sie brauchte dafür nur
in meinem freundes und bekanntenkreis
herum gucken
für die ist halt ein schnitzel oder eine
hühnerbrust aus dem supermarkt nehmen
das gleich als ob sie ein joghurt nehmen
oder müsliriegel oder sonst irgendetwas
da ist kein großer unterschied und die
wissen auch nicht was dahinter steht und
dass wir so weit weg gekommen sind von
einer tötung oder nicht von der tötung
von dem wissen was eine tötung heißt und
was ist vor allem bedeutet wenn wir
jetzt auch dieses tape kaufen und nach
einer woche müll schmeißen weil ist halt
abgelaufenen schade drum
das ist finde ich sehr erschreckend
ehrlich gesagt dass das in deutschland
so passiert das und sehe da auch ein
großen fehler irgendwie im
bildungssystem bei uns johanna du nicht
auch ein bisschen schritt nach vorne
gegangen ich sehe es genauso also wir
müssen definitiv gerade wenn es um
fleisch geht wieder bewusster essen und
uns klar machen das natürlich für dieses
stück fleisch und tier gestorben ist und
das finde ich sehr sehr wichtig sagt
dass auch leuten immer wieder gerne
kommt guckt euch unseren stall auch an
wenn wir für uns zuhause schlachten
guckt euch das meinetwegen auch mit an
alles kein problem weiß wirklich wieder
bewusster werden muss wie also gehe ich
voll mit klar vielleicht auch noch
wichtig die punkte natürlich geht es
darum dass wir den dialog finden führen
und auch eine lösung finden aber eben
auch gerade angesprochen
jeder muss für sich selbst entscheiden
was er oder sie für richtig hält das ist
ja eigentlich nicht die basis von moral
sondern man versucht gegensätzliche
meinungen zu weit vom konsens zu führen
dass man sagt hey was wäre denn für mich
persönlich gut was sind die goldenen
regeln da ethik und wenn ihnen möchte
dass mir etwas angetan wird findet kann
man überlegen warum tue ich das dann am
anderen lebewesen an und wenn man sagt
hey kann ich das für mich rechtfertigen
fleisch zu essen und damit tiere zu
töten ist eher die frage eigentlich
nicht ob ich es kann oder ob er es kann
oder sie sondern was es mit dem opfer
macht über das wollte meine eigene
sprechen weil dieses opfer ist ja der
leidtragende wir sehen denn der
privilegierten situation dass wir
darüber sprechen ohne überhaupt davon
betroffen zu sein deswegen findet
einfach wichtig sich das zu
vergegenwärtigen was das mit dem opfer
machen
also war es quasi mit entscheidung
getroffen und das die ist ja das problem
mir ist eigentlich total egal ob jemand
gerne chips in sich reinstopfen
und eis zum frühstück ist darum geht es
gar nicht das wirkliche persönliche
entscheidung aber sobald andere mit
involviert sind da ist eben der punkt wo
ich sage okay da schalte ich mich ein
weil das ist mein thema mir geht ums
schwein ich um den mensch vielleicht
kann man aber eine bessere entscheidung
treffen indem man vielleicht mehr für
das stück fleisch zahlt oder weniger ist
besser ist auf jeden fall die frage
setzen würden wir vielleicht bei johanna
nicht über den halben quadratmeter
sprechen sondern über drei quadratmeter
kommt dann nicht auch als frage dazu
oder her kann euch ein ein teures stück
biofleisch überhaupt noch leisten
das fleisch solcher billig produkt sein
muss jeden tag gekauft und das worauf
sie ein mann aus fleisch oder
milchprodukte kommen möchte gerne eine
frage stellen ja du betreibst zusammen
mit einem freund einen youtube kanal der
hass vegan ist ungesund und euch ist es
wichtig über veganismus aufzuklären über
klischees zu sprechen und auch andere
leute natürlich dafür zu begeistern und
zu überzeugen ihr seid für diesen
youtube-kanal sogar mal in einen
schweinestall eingebrochen was kommt ihr
denn da als erstes im kopf wenn du an
diesem tag denkst also ich weiß dass ich
bis zu dem punkt als ich vor dem
schweinestall stand sehr aufgeregt war
weil ich nicht wusste was mit mir
passiert als ich habe mir gedacht hoffen
muss man gucken wir was das mit mir
macht und dann als ich die ferkel gehört
habe muss ich sagen habe ich echt ein
kloß im hals gehabt und das erste was
ich weiß dass ich ein gang mann ist das
tatsächlich todes hergelaufen boden lag
in der mülltonne und neben dem eingang
und der gestank
also ist einfach so ein unfassbar
beißender geruch von ammoniak in der
luft und ich habe einfach mich ein
bisschen machtlos gefühlt
ich habe einfach diese tiere gesehen und
wie gesagt ich habe einen hund zu hause
und ich habe überall meinen hund gesehen
weil das alles noch babys waren und
darüber stand ein schild ich wieder tot
sind und wir noch leben ich habe immer
noch schwierigkeiten also ich hab das ja
immer noch bisschen schwierigkeiten das
verarbeiten ich merke auch dass ich das
oft verdrängen im alltag weil letztlich
ich kann eine situation nichts ändern
und damit muss ich leben
alles was ich machen kann es so gut es
geht darüber zu sprechen aufzuklären und
am ende des tages ist jeder mensch nach
hause und entscheidet sich was ja sicher
verpackt oder nicht johanna was denkst
du denn dazu also wir selber halten
keine sein wir haben was tiere bei uns
im stall aber allein schon diese stall
einbrüche finde ich einfach unter aller
sau denn letztendlich ist es ein
hausfriedensbruch was so nicht
funktioniert ich bin der meinung ich
kenne viele land würde wir selber machen
es genauso einfach mal durch rufen eine
e mail schreiben whatsapp was weiß ich
hey ich bin kann ich mir bei euren stall
angucken überhaupt kein problem aber
diese stall einbrüche gehen für mich
einfach gar nicht also endlich kann die
selben stall horror aufnahmen machen die
kannst du auch bei uns im stall machen
unsere buchten bayer weiter weil sie hat
doch dann ging es wieder ausreden sind
wie eine aufgebaut da stelle ich mich
nachts rein klatscht in die hände
die laufen alle in eine ecke dann mache
ich ein foto und habe massentierhaltung
und tiere dicht gedrängt dass eigentlich
der doppelte platz da ist sagt mir
keiner genau das ist auch das problem
bei den ganzen dokumentation horror
aufnahmen kann ich überall macht ja das
ist aber hat das stimmt aber nicht hab
sowas auch schon gemacht
das stimme nicht und ich hab so ich war
auch schon mal in einem betrieb kann ich
ihn was betrieb und das oder oft nachts
nicht offiziell ja wir haben da tote
tiere gesehen wir haben da tiere
mitgenommen
die nicht mal an die nippel trinken kam
weil sie gebrochene beine hatten
und da kann ja auch karten da geht doch
auch keiner durch der liegen teilweise
tiere es gibt aufnahmen und des skandal
an der sache ist ja eigentlich auch dass
solche aufnahmen nur über
tierschützerinnen überhaupt in die
medien kommen und die aufnahmen gibt es
ja dass der tote tiere wochenlang
zwischen lebenden legen liegen
das liegt ja keiner da hin wo tote tiere
mit in die betriebe genommen werden es
mag sein wir haben definitiv betriebe in
den autos nicht hin da gebe ich euch
vollkommen gerecht aber andere betriebe
schlecht zu machen
die ordentlich arbeiten weil tote tiere
mit in die ställe genommen werden um
entsprechende belaste dafür 30 erstmal
mich ganz gut sagen dass bei uns also
zwei sachen erstens bei uns im stall
wurden über zwei wochen aufnahmen
gemacht und versteckter kamera und es
wurden unfassbar brutale zustände
aufgedeckt die nie aufgedeckt worden
wären wenn wir nicht da gewesen wären so
gefragt zweitens wir waren bei stern tv
oder eine expertin die nicht vegan lebt
die nichts mit uns zu tun hat die
bestätigt hat dass das normal ist fern
tvs auch der sender hier was müssen wir
jetzt sogar eine landwirtin jetzt gerade
erst wurde aber erst mal n tv mit in
teilgenommen wollte man zeigen wie es
wirklich aussieht und zack wurde der
spieß wieder umgedreht und es wurde ins
negative gedreht aber auch einfach damit
leid fühlende lebewesen sind die da
nicht sein möchten so dass die menschen
ertragen die bilder nicht weil sie
brutal sind aber weil wir sie einfach
nicht sehen egal ob die tiere bisschen
mehr platz haben das dritte was ist ein
letzte was ich noch dazu sagen wollte
war ich kann dir sagen wenn ich auf
diese situation hätte verzichten können
diese posttraumatische
belastungsstörungen hätte ich das sehr
gerne getan glaubt man hasst es nicht
warum bist du nach seinem steuer
eingebrochen weil ich der überzeugung
weil diese wenn die tiere selber ein
mikrofon hätten und einen youtube kanal
hätten indem sie darüber reden können
wie es ihnen geht hätte ich ihnen gerne
die plattform gegeben aber das ist ein
bisschen so wie wenn das ein haus das
und das ist das ding was ich nicht
verstehe wenn man ist voller hunde
gewesen wäre
die leute lernen auf die straße gegangen
manche hunde an es gibt leute die halten
hass kinder ein raum wohnen aber das
mache ich doch auch ländern messer
das hat ja damit etwas zu tun genauso
spaß das ist ja gebaut ist und wir
sprechen jetzt gerade über schweine und
wir sprechen über massentierhaltung und
wir sprechen aber als überein aber es
ist auch liebe ist ja dass fröhlich über
die milch ist gerade halt auch du fühlst
dich natürlich extrem angegriffen
zurecht denke ich mal weil es bei euch
eben nicht so läuft und ich weiß nicht
wie seid ihr denn zum beispiel der wege
und ich habe ja nur berichtet also ich
hab ja noch nicht mal mit ihr gesprochen
ich habe nur berichtet was ich da
gesehen ja auch nur um den aber auch
also ihr gesagt hat auch das ist halt
standard das ist normal und so weiter
und das hat mir einer gesagt oder also
das ist also es ist natürlich
standardisiert massentierhaltung ist
standardisiert er heute noch erkennen
könnt ihr dann verstehen dass sie sich
davon eine angegriffen fühlt von dieser
formulierung dass es standardisiert ist
weil sie sich mühe gibt dass es bei ihr
anders ist ich kann es verstehen auch
dass du dich persönlich angegriffen
fühlt das ist ein daily business und
vielleicht magst du die schweine auch
trotzdem gehen die am ende auf die
schlachtbank und das find ich zum
beispiel moralisch verwerflich sondern
ich auch genauso verwerflich dass der
konsument hingeht im supermarkt und
genau für diese haltungsform bezahlt
natürlich auch das also ist es gibt das
ist das hat mehrere seiten gerne jetzt
über die eine gesprochen
das war super also ich finde es super
wichtigen punkt also ich sag mir geht es
auch nicht darum irgendjemandem also wir
haben auch als wir da waren wir haben ja
noch nicht mal den stall angezeigt weil
ich von vornherein gesagt habe ich
möchte ihnen zeigen mir geht es nicht
darum ein beispiel zu zeigen
zu sagen der ist aber scheiße der ist
doof sind dann mir geht es darum zu
sagen wenn wir als konsumentinnen das
nicht kaufen dann gibt es das auch nicht
so das heißt wir sind auf jeden fall mit
in der größten verantwortung
du machst dein job du machst das was du
vielleicht gelernt hast du bist du
aufgewachsen du bist so sozialisiert das
sind wir auch worden ich meine ich bin
in einer position ich habe wenn ich
unter anderen umständen aufgewachsen
meine eltern vielleicht landwirte beide
wären dann wäre ich vielleicht auch da
jetzt weiß ich nicht ich bin es aber
nicht insofern natürlich kann ich
verstehen dass du dich verärgert fest
ich verstehe dass man sich angegriffen
fühlt ich es war auch keine persönliche
reise ich alles gut es geht mir auch
nicht um dich persönlich sondern um den
fakt kannst du denn
trotzdem verstehen das ist
offensichtlich viele ställe gibt bei
denen es so läuft wie es bei denen läuft
womit ich nicht sagen will dass es bei
dir auch so ist natürlich ist es ein
problem dass wir diese schwarzen schafe
haben
das ist gar keine frage es ist jetzt
aber gerade für mich keinen grund mich
schritt nach vorne zu gehen wir müssen
missstände aufdecken aber letztendlich
ist das der job von von veterinärämtern
die art und weise nachts und den stall
zu gehen funktioniert hat
würde mich tatsächlich interessieren was
ihr dazu denkt findet ihr das so stall
einbrüche zum allgemeinen abschrecken
okay sind alina du bist jägerinnen und
du ist vor allem das fleisch was du auch
selbst geschossen hast und trotzdem
liebst du tiere du hast mehrere hunde
wo ist da der unterschied zwischen
deinen hunden und den reden die du
schießt
ich selber war auch vier jahre vier
jahren vegetarierin und das aus gründe
neben der haltungsform habe aber
irgendwann so nach vier jahren irgendwie
gemerkt dass mir das fleisch einfach
fehlt bekommt vom geschmack vom einfach
so will ich wollte es wieder meinem
leben haben und habe mir dann gedacht
wie mache ich das am besten so dass es
für mich wo wir das schöne wort haben
moralisch am vertrieb basten ist also
grundsätzlich denke ich immer es gibt
die entscheidung ist fleisch ja oder
nein dann ist die nächste dann ist
bewusst dass für meine fleischkonsum ein
tier sterben muss und dann beschäftige
ich mich damit wie muster sterben und
für mich ist auf die jagd gehen die
vertretbare lösung sage ich mal
weil ich setze kein zaun ich schreibe
niemandem was vor ich gebe keine
medikamente ich ja ich bin eigentlich
sagen mal zaungast des lebens okay was
sagt ihr dazu kommt er einen schritt auf
alena zu
also prinzipiell kann ich das schon
verstehen und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wer fleisch isst muss in meiner
wahrnehmung das tier auch zerlegen töten
uns erlegen können
das können ja die wenigsten weil die
würden wahrscheinlich einfach am
nervenzusammenbruch brechen zerbrechen
oder beziehungsweise könnten es
wahrscheinlich nicht mal töten
und ich finde gerade das thema jagd ist
auch sehr komplex also ich glaube auch
nicht dass wir das jetzt bis zum ende
durchspielen aber das klingt ja sehr
kleinteilig und jäger erlegen im jahr
auf 5 millionen tiere
was mich aber interessieren würde
würdest du auch deine hunde essen
niemand würde ich nicht essen aber ich
würde auch nicht gut ich zu hause heute
oder eine ziege die ich zu hause hatte
das ist für mich haustiere die ich bei
mir habe und ein wildtier ist für mich
ein frei lebendes tier zu dem ich
keinerlei beziehung habe außer eben die
in dem moment wo ich sehe und entscheide
ob ich es eben schießt oder nicht aber
ich habe keine persönliche beziehungen
dazu ich frage mich halt wirklich wenn
wir alle alternativen haben wir haben
einfach eine so bunte pflanzliche küche
wir haben inzwischen alternativen
bändigen wollen wir müssen es nicht wir
können aber dann alles ersetzen was von
geschmacks super nahe an das original
das original rankommt eine weiße
menschen sagen ich könnte mir das gar
nicht vorstellen aber sie haben doch gar
nicht ausprobiert apropos ausprobieren
und ich habe meine frage an euch alle
jetzt lässt würdet ihr insekten essen
wenn ja dann kommt man ein schritt auf
mich zu und wenn nein dann geht ein
schritt zurück
ok malo sein unternehmen verkauft vegane
fleischersatz produkte aber auch
produkte aus insekten würdest du sagen
dass burger pettys aus käfern und
würmern die lösungen der zukunft sind
es ist ein teil der lösung möglich zu
sein
ich glaube dass die zukunft durchaus
hauptsächlich wegen aussehen wird aber
ich denke das wird nicht für alle für
alle befriedigend sein und da müssen
mehr alternativen her und ich glaube
dass vielleicht eigenen thema sein wird
was interessant ist aber auch insekten
das für eine vielfalt brauchen wir nicht
jeder ist mit mit mit tofu mit soja
alternativen mit proteinen zufrieden ich
glaube die meisten sind nicht zufrieden
damit weil es noch nicht ausprobiert
haben und ich hab ja wie im vorschlag
machen ist ja auch es geht nicht um
unsere zufriedenheit beim essen und die
fünf minuten sondern es geht um das was
das für konsequenzen für den absolut
stimmig 100 prozent vollkommen richtig
ich denke wir haben riesen klimaproblem
wir das ganze thema werden das thema
tier wohl aber beleuchtet aber wir haben
auch eine riesenshow die
massentierhaltung sorgt ein paar dafür
dass wir den planeten nicht länger
überleben kann wenn wir so weitermachen
war ganz kurzer zum allgemein
verständlich werden schon mal gefragt
das ist ein bisschen untergegangen was
ist dann massentierhaltung ist es
massentierhaltung wenn ich zehn schweine
hat wenn ich 100 schweine habe oder wenn
ich 10 tausend schweine hat wo geht
massentierhaltung los das ist das ist
die frage die sich mir immer wieder
stellt warum ist dieser wichtige frage
also natürlich ein mehr tiere auf
engstem raum gehalten werden desto
schlimmer sind im durchschnitt zumindest
sowohl die haltungsbedingungen als auch
die klimafolgen aber ob das jetzt so und
so viel betrieb betriebe gibt darin hat
ist relativ irrelevant aber wissen dass
die summe kumulativ der
massentierhaltung der größte flächen
verbraucher wasserverbrauch ist der
größte regenwald abholzen der größte
verbraucher von antibiotika und wie man
wir sehen pandemien wir leben in einer
die jetzt auf dem bild im markt kommt
aber wenn wir uns weiter angucken und
auch experten und theologen fragen dann
stehen kommende pandemien unter anderem
aufgrund der industrie lassen sie darum
bevor und das ist alles wo es dann
plötzlich nicht mehr um das individuum
geht und meine persönliche entscheidung
sondern kumulativ um die weltgesundheit
und das ganz anders ran also
massentierhaltung
die massentierhaltung bei insekten ist
ein anderes thema als bei anderen tieren
insekten sind kaltblüter und die wollen
ganz gerne nah beieinander wohl
dementsprechend sind die prädestiniert
dafür um sie im massentierhaltung halten
zu können
und von daher bieten die unglaublich
großes potenzial die im vertical farming
im bereich zu halten ich bin immer
wieder verwundert leute haben im grunde
genommen oft ein ekel gegenüber insekten
aber bevor sie anfangen der pflanzliche
alternative zu nehmen reden über
insekten bürgern finden dass fehler
bezüglich ansagen nähe sondern pflanzen
wird es folglich das finde ich schwierig
aber ich denke dass es auf jeden fall
weniger schlecht ist als das was wir in
der industriellen massentierhaltung
machen ich denke dass die zukunft aber
eher in der zellbasierten landwirtschaft
liegt wo wir den umweg über die kuh und
schwein und business act weglassen sagen
wir züchten von der zellen machen daraus
fleisch und haben wir die allermeisten
probleme gar nicht mehr nico nächste
frage an dich als
ernährungswissenschaftler beschäftigst
du dich mit fleisch alternativen die
noch in der entwicklung sind
würdest du sagen das klingt also das
fleisch aus dem reagenzglas dass das die
zukünftige lösung sein wird
also ich denke und da wird man
wahrscheinlich alle einig seien die
menschheit wird mit den absehbarer zeit
auf und fleisch zu essen
ich denke aber dass es in der bar
zehnten vergangenheit sein wird dass der
großteil der menschheit fleisch aus
einem tier ist sondern man wird diesen
extravaganten umweg über das tier ganz
einfach weglassen und die zelle
kultivieren und somit einen großen teil
fast alle einig sein und somit einen
großen teil an treibhausgas emissionen
und wasserverbrauch und landverbrauch
sparen und so können wir nicht nur
klimafreundlichere sondern hat auch
gesundheitsförderliche produkte kreieren
und das gleiche geschmackserlebnis haben
es wird mit sicherheit trotzdem noch
tierhaltung geben kleinen maße war das
große problem der massentierhaltung die
einer der größten probleme unserer
gesellschaft sind die gehören
zukünftigen vergangen haben was sagt ihr
dazu bewegt euch das wird dich jetzt
werden schritt nach hinten
ja ich stimme dir zum teil zu ich glaube
dass in vitro fleisch was sie gerade
angesprochen hat spricht das fleisch aus
dem reagenzglas nicht unsere zukunft
sein wird ich glaube aber das fleisch
ganz klar in den hintergrund rücken wird
und dass wir vielleicht
der verteilung von 90 vegane produkte 10
fleischprodukte haben werden so glaube
ich schon dass ich sehr gut aber damals
einige hörbar zumindest schon mal an dem
punkt einer meinung dass man
alternativen suchen sollte deswegen zeit
für die letzte runde
erste frage sollten wir die
mehrwertsteuer von fleisch von sieben
prozent auf 19 prozent erhöhen und die
zusätzlichen einnahmen in die
verbesserung des tirols stecken wenn ihr
mir zustimmt dann kommt da jetzt ein
schritt auf mich zu was wäre die
alternative
die was wäre die alternative eigentlich
sollten wir das jetzt ein eher schwierig
das problem dass wir was wir da haben es
ja fehlende transparenz werden die sagen
okay pass auf neben dass mehr geld
investieren ist ein besseres ihr wollt
dann was das dann konsument oder kommen
konsumentinnen macht ist ja letztlich
okay ich kann jetzt fleisch mit gutem
gewissen kaufen und super und ich sollte
ja okay jetzt kind johanna sagt nein
bleibt stehen
es sollte klar keine frage müsste mehr
beim landwirt ankommen bin ich der
meinung gar nicht damit der landwirt
jetzt öfter den urlaub fahren kann oder
sich ein ding audi kauft sondern um es
dann in die tierhaltung zu stecken gar
keine frage
mit einer steuer finde ich schwierig
dass da bin ich sehr skeptisch dass es
funktioniert warum und warum weil du
hast so zweckgebunden nicht erteilt
bekommst wirklich der meine und einfach
nur jetzt pauschal zu sagen fleisch muss
teurer werden finde ich auch komplett
falsch und letztendlich hängt da immer
wieder der der lebensmitteleinzelhandel
brille und und und wo das meiste geld
zumindest heute hängen bleibt zwölfte
frage in allen öffentlichen kantinen
also schule universitäten unternehmen
usw sollten in zukunft mindestens ein
drittel vegane gerichte und ein dritte
vegetarische gerichte angeboten werden
nur eintritt ein drittel ein drittel ein
drittel ein drittel von traurig und ein
drittel fleisch jeden tag sind wir noch
zwei drittel fleisch das
kommen wir zum letzten lösungsvorschlag
dreizehnte frage von 13 fragen
deutschland sollte deutlich mehr geld in
die forschung von clean meet investieren
denn wir in zukunft fleisch essen wollen
dann sollte dafür kein tier mehr getötet
werden müssen
stimmt ihr zu hier bleibt stehen du bist
du schon drin was ist das kommt weiß ich
nicht aber ich finde ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen mit fleisch aus dem
reagenzglas habe ich mich noch überhaupt
nicht mit beschäftigt und möchte
deswegen auch jetzt wieder ein schritt
vor noch zurück ins johanna du sagst
nein richtig okay dann konnten wir
leider als einzige das ziel ich jetzt
einfach mal zumindest als ein halbes
hier im kompromiss drin gesehen aber du
bist ja trotzdem sehr nah auf die andere
seite zu bekommen ihr seid euch
grundsätzlich sehr nahe gekommen dass
ich sehr nah gekommen das bin ich schön
danke auf jeden fall für eure zeit und
für das herzige diskutieren
also ich fand einfach sehr schön dass
wir tatsächlich wieder ein stück weit
auch zusammengekommen sind nicht ganz
aber fast oder allgemein finde es
einfach schlimm diese pauschalierung das
wirklich an alle betriebe da irgendwo
über einen kamm geschert werden das
funktioniert einfach nicht
es geht mir darum klarzustellen ich
verstehe bis heute nicht und ich werde
es nie verstehen wenn wir eine option
haben der während teelichte müssen warum
sollen wir diese nicht wählen
interessant waren sie auch den verlauf
der ganzen spielrunde das mahlow und
aber gewissen punkt auch alena dir auf
der gegenseite unter anführungszeichen
standen dann auch relativ schnell auf
unserer seite aber gerade auch mal das
ist wie gesagt es geht ja hier nicht um
diese seite gegen diese seite sondern es
geht darum mit unterschiedlichen
standpunkten und sichtweisen gemeinsam
lösungswege zu finden
ich werde weiterhin
fleischalternativen essen aber natürlich
auch ein teil fleisch essen und somit zu
den flex italien gehören ich denke das
ist der weg den auch viele andere
deutsche gehen sollten und der
sicherstellt dass wir eine eine gesunde
und gute zukunft haben
wir freuen uns sehr wenn sie unseren
kanal abonniert das könnt ihr hier macht
hier oben findet ihr eine weitere folge
13 fragen sehr spannend zum thema denn
dann ja oder nein und hier unten ein
weiteres video zum aktuellen thema
[Musik]